hey I'm Penn Badgley I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I am here to answer your
burning questions
so if you haven't seen you season -
don't know but there's spoilers here so
you're just gonna want to watch this
later or spoil it for yourself if you
don't have discipline of any kind
alright this once ooh so hot what was it
like filming the scene where Joe cleans
up Jasper's body after killing cleans up
not sure about that language was it the
most gruesome see cuz he puts him in a
meat grinder by the way was it the most
gruesome scene for you to film yes yeah
no actually so here's a spoiler yeah
when Delilah is dead on the floor of the
cage with her throat slashed the amount
of fake blood that was required to make
that look real was more gruesome next
question what was the original audition
process life it didn't audition I'm
kidding well I met Greg and Sarah they
apparently you know very much wanted me
for and and and it was really ultimately
my conversations with them that that
made me overcome my my pesky moral
conflict over playing such a guy but you
had another part of the question how did
you hear about the project my agent
nothing nothing mysterious they're one
of the biggest episodes in season two
was definitely when Joe and 40 trip on
LSD I agree any fun memories from
filming those episodes yeah yeah that
was actually the most fun for me I think
because it was the most physical the
most strange and maniacal yeah jumping
out of the window was fun we actually
had to do more stunts than you see
really then so yeah it's always fun to
do physical stuff trying to act as
though I'm you know like weeping and
tripping at the same time that's
interesting that's fun it's also
exhausted since the show is heavily
based on voiceover what's it like
filming are there long pauses to
accommodate the voiceover yes there are
or is there dialogue that is eventually
cut now there's no dialogue so this is
something that I've gotten for a good at
and that or at least I'm used to it and
then all the other actors have to learn
as well which I think for them when it's
new is always very jarring we have
somebody this season it was my stand-in
Danny
shoutout to Danny it's not getting paid
enough because he had the to a lot more
than a never been an ordinary standin
he's also in the 8th episode by the way
he is the he is the spoiler alert man
whose wife has to kiss 40 so it's a
thankless role but we were really happy
to see him on camera he reads my
voiceovers it's really strange to be
honest it's very technical it's not like
normal acting at all when did you find
out about the love twist at the end of
season 2
did you know before you started filming
a season I did know I found out when I
first read with Victoria pedretti who
plays love Greg and Sarah told me after
she left the room and we were talking
about you know she was talented and it
wasn't up to me but they were like you
know kind of including me in the process
and then and Greg just said do you want
to know and I said yeah that helped and
he's like alright so she's a killer and
I was like oh interesting but what they
didn't tell me was that Joe would not
like that I thought I just imagined like
okay so we're gonna go on some weird
Bonnie and Clyde season three kind of
thing and that maybe that won't maybe
that still will happen I don't know I
departed I didn't know about that I was
upset about was a Joe I mean it is
consistent with Joe wouldn't accept love
that really hurt my heart but again it's
morally consistent with Joe's immorality
what's your favorite behind-the-scenes
memory from filming you season two damn
it's it's a real it's like a blur
because I just there's so much that I
have to do for some reason what's coming
to mind is the fact that I wasn't able
to work with John Stamos again which is
a deep pain I can't talk about it
but when I saw him I forgot that he was
in it and then I saw him and I was like
get them out of here John Stamos is in
this show and he looks amazing in his in
his jumper and
you think Joe definitely wants to find
true love no and do you sit with
actually okay to be fair to his humanity
because we all need to worry about Joe
so you man it anymore
yeah I think he does want to find your
bow but he is no effing clue where to
find it or how to which is you know like
a lot of us and do you think that he's
found out with no no they both kill
people okay
oh good that'd be true love I'm not I
don't want a police people's feelings
anymore it's really exhausting what what
has it been like seeing response to Joe
online it's been interesting is it odd
for you to see people lusting after
character that doesn't hear me bad no
because again I mean come on look where
we are like it's not weird it's it's
consistent with where we are so I think
it makes a lot of sense and thank God we
can have these kinds of conversations
around it you know all of my like moral
policing is just is it good humor
tongue-in-cheek I hope everybody
understands that do you think that love
is equally as bad as Joe I mean yeah
like issue different probably yeah has
he finally met his match yeah apparently
you'll have to tune in won't you I don't
know though I mean it's not up to me I
just make the words come to life what
can you tease about the neighbor at the
end of the season I know literally
nothing here's my theory it says do you
have any theories yeah I think they're
probably not gonna use the woman in cast
because they didn't know what they were
gonna do this is the way this is the way
like television works no matter if it's
good or bad or anything in between
it's just you can't know more than where
you're at there's so much that goes into
writing a season conceiving a season for
the writers I mean they've got to arc
out I mean it's just it's it's a lot an
organizational frigging feet yeah I mean
he had to go back to his original Joe
pattern of literally the grass was
always greener to get us out of the
fence this fantasy I I'm most interested
in what's gonna happen between love and
Jill because they have a child spoiler
alert it'd be great if I was it spoiler
spoiler alert after I always spoil
that's what I'm gonna start doing yeah I
have no theories I think I I think I
think that it's probably not gonna go in
the direction that it seems like it is
right at the end I think it's probably
gonna like they're gonna do what they
want and
deal with the neighbor I don't know
killer it's terrible you can't even joke
about it thank you so much for tuning in
if you haven't yet please check out you
season two on Netflix not the first
season
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]